Listening to radiolab radio found W and Y.
N. P. R. How did you even get on to field?
I feel like buttons has just become a fixture. How did this happen?
It can boost the blade for me. Let me, let me start. I'm going to start.
This was reported a lot of Nassar and today on Radio Lab blockers and I are
bringing Jed and you three wildly different stories about buttons that are
really about
power and freedom and destruction.
So this all started because I could not convince any of my friends to go to the
elevator history museum with me.
There was not a single person out of the eight and a half million people living
in New York who wanted to go to the button museum with wait,
you found one except I'll recall.
I'll go the Annie Fair. Exactly. Okay.
Jamie told me never to stop recording but so we go to long island city like walk
around. You think it's right that door right there. I personally can't find it.
We got lost. This street is entirely taxi yellow.
Only thing we saw was a big old boring building covered with with with taxi
signs. We have no interest in taxes.
Do you know if there's a museum in here and we found some guy on the street?
Yes there is. Um, you gotta go up to stairs, right? Yeah.
That's great. I'll take you, I'll take me. I'll show you the way. Anyway.
All right. You go along the way down. They go. Left Greg. Nick,
a walkway down to the edge. Thank you very much. Aha. Wow.
That's quite a sign. Elevated Museum founded in 2011 by Patrick Carson.
So we open up the door. Wow.
We have no idea what's going to be on the other side of this, not the thing.
Whoa. This is different from what? Like it's a large room.
It's a world. Are you building up to something? It's filled with, what is it?
What stuff? Elevator. Matchbook here.
Pens or witches and locks. Just random stuff.
Is there things you give the sales meetings? Yeah, the Rosenberg loop. Again,
small breaths. Objects of one kind or another.
And there are these giant paintings of escalators and moving sidewalks and
sitting in a corner. Hi, I'm Leptin across the room.
We see a guy sitting, he's a, an older guy, Patrick car.
He has his glasses down on his nose and he's in charge of the place.
They can call me if they want to come visit.
(718) 361-8683 apparently you're supposed to make an appointment and if I'm
going to move, they'll get a song.
Patrick has been the lead singer in a number of bands and he even studied
constitutional law out. This is a man for all seasons. He's like,
he's got so much elevator stuff.
I've been collectors of 11 years old because when you were seven years old,
you walked into an elevator and had a million years old.
I started working with my dad. I went to college,
got a couple of degrees and stayed in the elevator. Never left. I actually,
my first item is over on one of the walls here. Well,
let me show you something up. Bring you over here.
And as we're walking along like a haul of buttons,
we kind of inevitably do a series of elevator button panels.
Here's a golden up and down. Here's a bronze up in that, oh,
that's a really silver up and down. He has all kinds of antique buttons that,
I mean from just different era. Some is one where you go split.
So this is the genesis, right?
This is where the insults begins and it is an insult because what is about to
happen is he's about to tell us that we are fools and have no power in the world
in which he inhabits. And he does that by pointing to the close door button.
You know when you push in, the door's supposed to close, he says, just says,
matter of fact, it's just about 80% of them are nonfunctional. Oh Wow.
Because they are broken and no one fixed them because they never wired.
They were never, never wired up. Never. Most of the time we don't do it,
but 80% of them don't work.
I just assume they don't where you assume they don't lie. See the time. Yeah,
I saw it. No, no, no, no, no work. No, I cannot be right.
What do you mean you cannot be right?
Have you ever 40 close button that has had, I believe I on the door.
Psychological tool for you. You needed a button to go back to that person,
but that's not the bin. He said also he had also a very fancy reason.
What was his fancy reason? They're extremely intelligence.
All of it is the yellow is actually, remember what happens every day.
So the elevator system knows that between eight 55 and nine o'clock we get 373
people at an average morning coming in.
So we're going to return to cause to the main floor as soon as we possibly can.
We're not going to park anything up upstairs,
but it knows that at four 45 it gets 650 people leaving the building.
You get three wheelchairs, you get two old people that Dah Dah, Dah.
And so we programmed the timing of the elevator to accommodate the hole.
So all you're doing is screwing up our timing by touching that thing.
I mean you have thousands and thousands of people anxiously trying to urge the
machine to do their will.
Like watching people just keep pressing a stupid button and not know.
I mean this is cruel.
I have to tell you his idea that we would somehow have the authority or the
power to close the door. It was offensive to him. Yeah, no. In my building,
they work. I'm sympathetic to that viewpoint.
Be sympathetic because think of what a building is.
It's a crazy ass vertical stack of humanity.
How is that going to work if not for beautifully designed systems like the
elevator. This is about freedom. This is about freedom and this is about Sade.
Your head say no.
He then began looking around for some little soup song of hope to give the
Radiolab listeners some tiny bit of power that they can have back in this
otherly fascistic system and you know we found it. You did. We did.
What did you find? We have clothes. We have hacked the close button. Really?
Wait, now I'm suddenly into for the first
time I am interested in what? What? What did you discover the next time, Chad,
that you walk into an elevator, the door closes and mysteriously,
although you're going to the eighth floor, it stops on five. The door opens.
You appear out. There's nobody there. Yes.
Six endless seconds will roll by leaving you powerless and hapless,
but not anymore. Now, here's what you can do. And we checked this,
and it's true. You can put your arm through the door,
breaking the beam with your arm and then Yank your arm back very suddenly.
That will convince the stupid, stupid,
supine elevator that you have.
Just someone had just entered the elevator and now it will close.
[inaudible] really amazing. Three. Yay. Five seconds off your waiting time.
They will give you that sense of doing. So.
Yeah, that's 45 minutes of your life. You're welcome.
I should just say,
Patrick was actually really awesome guy and everyone should visit the elevator.
His rooms. Yeah.
So the next story,
this is the maybe the most valuable button in the world. Hmm. It's not a button.
Exactly. It's, it's the, he was a guy and his name was button. Gwinette.
Why does it button Gwinnette, B u, t, t, O n is that his real name?
That's his real name.
But that's Bobby Livingston from rnr auction house in Boston who is button
Gwinette button.
Gwinnette is one of two signers of the declaration of independence that were
born in England and moved to the United States or move to the colonies.
He is a founding father. He's a founding father.
You've seen his signature thousands of times without realizing it. And,
and the thing about that signature, it gets interesting in a minute,
but just to start at the beginning,
buttoned Gwinnett was born in England in the early 17 hundreds and then he moved
to Georgia in 1765 and he
bought an island and I believe he began a import export island.
Yup. St Catherine's island. The truth is he leased it, but whatever.
So he's like a, just a wealthy guy. No button.
Gwinnett was a serial debtor actually, and he owed everybody.
He owed everybody money.
So he failed in his business and he became a radicalized revolutionary.
And he joined Georgia politics late in the 1760s and when it got to be 1776 in
Philadelphia,
he was in independence hall and he signed the Declaration of independence really
to the left and below a John Hancock.
But then he goes home to Georgia and gets in a duel with this political rival
and is killed in 1777 and then I believe in 1780 his wife passes away leaving
only his daughter,
and then by 1800 his daughter passes away and his lineage is so Gwinnett pass
into history. Yes.
[inaudible]
yeah, his signature is on that very important piece of paper. True. True.
Which becomes important because around the 1820s the last of the signers,
the declaration of independence were dying.
So there was a nostalgia for the founding fathers and that's when people began
collecting the signatures that were placed on that document.
So people collected Jefferson and an Adams and a Hancock and they started
thinking, okay, I want a whole set of the 56 men that signed that document.
People want the set, they want the set for an American.
I don't think there was any more important signature than the signatures that
were placed on that document.
Get them all in a problem arose button Gwinette signatures that were almost
impossible to find. And even now I can a hundred and some odd years later.
One Guy, uh, we,
I went to see his collection and he had a beautiful house in Florida, uh,
overlooking the bay. I won't tell you which bay,
but he showed me some great stuff and I said, what else you got? And he goes,
I swear you pushes a button on and a wall begins to rise.
Uh, and on the wall he's got like, you know, incredible. You Know Wilbur, right?
George Washington, but I could see in the middle, my eye goes right to it.
The unmistakable signature of button Gwinette is like the centerpiece of this
secret wall that [inaudible] is up. And I go, my goodness,
you've got to put in Gwinnette. It was pretty amazing.
So this is the autographic equivalent of some really famous diamond, you know,
or something like that. Right. You know, it's the holy grail. Wait,
how many signatures still exist?
There are 50 51 51 known examples in the world.
Most of the things that exist are IOUs. If you have one of these things,
what were they worth? Well, I'll tell you this,
it is more valuable than Lincoln.
Much more a hundred times more than a blink. And what really,
what about George Washington? Yup. Ben Franklin. Yes. Yes.
[inaudible] outsells upsells. Ben.
Ben Franklin was a world famous person, but Ben Franklin was a man of letters.
He wrote tons of letters. He was president of Pennsylvania.
He was the ambassador to France.
He wrote and wrote and wrote and signed and sign and sign. So there's
Bobby Livingston told us with the, with the exception,
possible exception of William Shakespeare, this guy bought button,
go net, ran up a bunch of debt, did basically nothing else that is like,
he is the most valuable signature in the world
today. What makes it extremely hard to complete a set of signers?
The decoration dependence is because of the 51 41 are in libraries or
institutions. And we'll never be able to get it.
So there's only 10 examples in public hands.
Hello Sir. Hello Sir. How you doing? Good. Okay. And you checked your,
your bags and everything.
So turns out that there are four button Gwinnett's at the,
at the New York Public Library, which is right in their neighborhood.
Closed the, I believe the reading room is still close,
but we're going to a kind of super secret place where you need to ring a bell to
get in. Really? So I, so I, I emailed them up,
I emailed the guy named Thomas Lannon and I work in the men's groups and
archives division at the New York Public Library.
He took us into a special room on the top, on the top floor. Ooh. Wow.
This is awesome. All by ourselves. We'll just,
I guess we'll put them on the word [inaudible]. I had a wooden,
like a kind of beautiful old wooden table and we have on the table four button
Gwinnett's for wait, hold on. Just, just so I can appreciate,
tell me what one of these is worth. What you don't know until they're sold.
Cause they're different quality.
But the last one that we know of that was sold here in New York was sold for
$722,500 dollars. I don't,
I'm not in the business of estimating value of things,
but I can say that button. When I autographs at the New York Public Library,
r w classified as splendid, highest ranking, splendid.
They're not, they're not simply um, cut autographs. There are documents signed.
Okay Fish, look at this. This is the most extravagant, oh wow.
But it has like seals on it like red wax seals.
They might've been like $4 million sitting on that table. We got $4 million.
Right. So for me, the, the impulse,
the impulse I'm having right here is not just putting these in my pocket and
running away. Like the impulse I'm having, and I'm being totally frank here,
is that, is it the same impulse I have?
Like you know when you want to pull the fire alarm,
like I just want to just tear these all up right now. Kind of,
I just wanted to take all of these papers that were on this table and just tear
them all the shred. I can't, I can't speak to here. Desire to, to,
to destroy history. And then the guy really looked alarmed, but you really,
you don't really want to tear these up. You have to admit it's just so bad.
Like it's so arbitrarily valuable. Like w like, like I could just,
I could just rip it up.
Like how could it be that valuable if I could just rip it up.
[inaudible]
okay, so taking a cue from lot of, when we come back,
we're going to take a decidedly n t button turn. We'll be right back. Okay.
This is Adrian Stein from New Brunswick, New Jersey.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Sofi,
a new kind of finance company. Here's the deal.
If you've invested in your career by taking out student loans.
Sofi wants to help Sofi, refinances,
federal and private student loans to cut interest rates and save its members an
average of $316 a month.
Learn more and find your savings@sofidotcomtermsandconditionsapplyatsofi.com
slash legal hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Morgan Stanley.
Your son has a gift for gymnastics.
Your daughter has her eye on a little startup in the valley and you want to
retire early.
How do you create a wealth plan that reflects all the complexity of a modern
family?
Start with a financial advisor who understands individuals and knows how to
bring families together around both shared m personal goals.
More information@morganstanley.com slash conversations Morgan Stanley Smith,
Barney, LLC. Members civic.
Hi, this is Kevin Murray from Fort Collins, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported by Fox searchlight pictures presenting Jackie from
director Pablo Lorraine and starring Natalie Portman as the iconic first lady.
Then Jacqueline Bouvier Kennedy. In the days following the assassination of JFK.
Natalie Portman delivers another Oscar caliber performance in a film that
reimagines the events through the eyes of Jackie herself as she fights to cement
her husband's historical legacy in select theaters. Now
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad. I've been rod today on the podcast.
Lots of Nasr and Robert Krulwich are talking buttons.
So we have one more button, Dale. In a way,
this sort of, once we were onto buttons,
this sort of presented itself because it is the most high stakes button.
Yeah, Mr President,
we have a crisis situation that one of our missiles centers a thermo nuclear
button. You want me to tell me a renegade?
General's got this finger on the button of a Titan missile.
Okay.
Is it a button? I mean, well that's what we want.
We want in Hollywood is a big red button. So we just figured, okay,
let's go find the button that destroys the world.
So we brought in a friend of mine, Alex [inaudible].
He's a historian of all things nuclear weapon related. Yeah.
You sat down and the first thing he told us was that there's no button,
no button, no, there has never been a single button. Well wait a second,
like don't.
When you get to like 1952 1953 in ordinary parlance, people say,
well the president has his finger on the button. I mean, I don't know.
Do you have any idea where that phrase comes from? But it's older.
It's much older than the bomb.
Oh [inaudible] so 1910s is when all of this stuff,
hg wells is sort of famous. But there's,
there's all this literature about the crazy scientist who invents a,
again,
a new form of gas that can like kill everybody and he has a button and is it a
red button? I don't know if they say red, but it's definitely a button.
And according to Alex, by the time develop nuclear weapons,
existing imagery about the scientists can blow up the world using their button
transfers to the president can blow up the world using his button.
And then Alex told us something that we really surprised us.
He said when the u s government dropped those first bombs on Japan,
so the bomb that they drop in Hiroshima,
they didn't take off with the bomb armed.
They took off with the bomb missing a piece. And the missing piece is a,
it's a chunk of uranium.
And then one of the scientists who was also a military guy,
crawled into the back of this plane while it was in route, opened up the bomb,
put the missing piece back into it,
and then closed it back up again and turned on all the electrical switches that
said, if we drop you out of the plane, you're going to have to detonate.
It will explode when it's a certain number of feet off the ground.
So pressure will trigger it. And as for finger on the button,
the finger, which belonged to Harry Truman,
president and States was 11 time-zones removed and frankly unaware of the act.
Truman, he didn't issue an order himself.
He sort of approved an order that was already being issued from the secretary of
war to the commanders out there. And it said,
you have to have these special bombs. That's what they called them,
special bombs. And here are your four targets. You can drop them on,
you can drop them on here. Shima you could drop on in Nagasaki,
you can drop them on Kookaburra and you could drop them on. You.
Gotta basically says at any day after August 3rd, feel free to drop some off.
What he said. Here's a couple of different options.
Choose cheers and bombs. Here's some cities, here's some days, go for it.
No Way. Other than that, the only considerations are operational.
So the bombing order says you have to be able to see the target before you drop
it. And uh, that's it. Wow.
One of the interesting things that I found out later, there was a,
a town called CoQuora and that was the plan B town or subsidy rather,
uh, for Hiroshima. But,
but the weather that day happened to be good in Hiroshima.
So they dropped it there and then the next time it was,
that was actually the plan, a city for Nagasaki. But the weather was bad there.
And so then they, they, they bombed Nagasaki. But so this, this,
the city of CoQuora got got spared twice,
like so close and so Truman doesn't even know he,
he gets told, oh by the way we dropped the bomb yesterday.
You mean when the bomb dropped in Hiroshima? He had no idea. No erosion.
He didn't know his room. No. What day? The second bomb,
he seems to have been caught off guard and he actually issues,
this is his only way of getting involved.
He issues an order which says stop dropping atomic bombs until I tell you to,
I feel like if you're a president and you're going to do that to that many
people you see, I feel like you should be directly responsible.
It should not be an arbitrary decision.
Like I kind of want a button in this case. No, no, no, no.
You actually want there to be a button, right? You could bump up button.
A button is too easy, right?
You don't want it to be easy enough that you set your coffee down on the Oval
Office table and like kill the world. Right?
Like obviously nobody wants to do that. Nobody wants to be that.
And I think it's, you know,
I have to admit when you first are pitching the button thing,
I was thinking where are they going to go with this? How is this going to work?
And the more I was thinking about it, it's sort of a deep concept, right?
It's about the ease in which you could actually destroy all of civilization
because of the technology which you could not do in the 19th century.
You could not do with Gangas Kahn. He could do a lot of damage,
but he could not kill, you know, all the people in the world.
[inaudible]
the button is the symbol of how easy that is.
And the reason this becomes kind of crucial as we now are moving through the
fifties and
the early sixties, the United States, uh, is in a face to face with,
with Khrushchev over at the Strip and missiles.
Normally it know what's going on. It's all in the vein of non Bam readiness
and the world gets you really, really, really close to annihilation.
The way that it works at this time is that the president has an assistant
Terry Guy who has all the nuclear codes in a briefcase,
a handcuffed to the assistant and the assistant.
If the president is in the bathroom,
the assistant is outside the door in the corridor.
If this president is at a football game at all times. So weirdly the,
the suitcase is called the football and I believe the page with the nuclear
launch codes on it is called the biscuit
y. I have no idea where it got the name. So it's the sixties
things between the u s and the Soviet Union are very tense.
And there are generals on the joint chiefs,
Curtis Lemay among them who are yeah, who are very,
who are not at all troubled by the possibility that this would be a weapon they
would use. And they advocated very specifically and very specific case.
So even though there are no buttons and there are all these codes,
people are still worried at the time about just how easy it would be for the
president to launch a nuclear
right. So in one guy in particular, this Guy Roger Fisher's,
this sort of academic policy guy, he's a Harvard law school professor.
He advised secretaries of state on the Iran hostage crisis on the Israel Egypt
peace accord. He,
he definitely had the ear of the Pentagon and he was troubled by this idea that,
you know,
the president could very dispassionately start nuclear war until we proposed
this idea. I'll jump in.
The notion comes from his long interest in reducing the risk of war.
Roger Fisher passed away, but we were able to talk to his two sons.
I'm Elliott Fischer, I'm a professor at Dartmouth and I'm Peter Fisher.
I'm a senior fellow at the Tuck School of business at Dartmouth.
So his solution to this, and by the way,
this would be just in the case of a of a u s surprise attacks,
what's called a first strike, was to,
instead of having all the codes be just in a suitcase,
this idea was to get a volunteer who would have the codes put under their heart.
You embed the codes in some sort of capsule and the guy's heart surgically and
he'd carry around a briefcase with a knife in it, a butcher knife,
and if the president ever felt the urge to fire off the missiles,
he has to go to the guy and say, well, now it's time. Give me the knife,
and then you would have to take the knife and
drive it into the guy's chest.
The president has to chop out this code from the sky's heart.
The president would have to kill someone and pull the code out of their body
that he would have to first kill one person in order to get at the codes that
would let him kill millions of people.
He has to look at someone and realize what death is.
Fischer writes a what an innocent death is blood on the White House carpet.
It's reality brought home.
Fisher then says that he suggested this to friends in the Pentagon and their
reply was, Mike God, that's terrible. Having to kill someone,
distort the president's judgment. He might never push the button.
That's the whole point. Yes. The strongest objection is it might work.
But even now I think, you know, Gosh,
not a crazy idea at all to have the president be,
if they're going to pull the trigger and blow the world up, kill one person.
Cause you're just about to kill tens of millions,
mostly innocent people and the button is just too easy.
So we'll just make it harder. Buttons too easy. Exactly. Yeah.
[inaudible]
yeah. The butcher knife is the ultimate anti-pop
but how you can find a guy to put, uh, the codes inside his heart. I, I would,
I would volunteer. I would volunteer to be that guy. Really,
you would totally second at a volunteer.
You wouldn't volunteer to be stabbed in the heart by the president of the United
States. You know what I would do? I would make like,
I'd be best friends with the president. We would take walks,
we would go swimming together. It would be great. We'd be best friends. I would,
I would,
that would be my mission would be to make it as hard as humanly possible for him
to carve them.
[inaudible]
okay. We have some thank you's to make here. Why don't you go ahead. All right.
Uh,
first thank you to Catherine kill a Chatzky of the elevator historical society
museum in Long Island City,
New York on the slate elevator company and pride and service elevator company
both in New York for helping us learn things and to our friend Steve who helped
us understand what goes on among, uh, autograph collectors.
Thank you to the very indulgent New York Public Library Archives and manuscripts
division. And Alex Wilson has a nuclear history blog.
He calls it restricted data. Check that out.
Alex in turn wanted us to thank John Coster, Mullen, Michael Gordon,
flosser and Spencer man special
thanks to actors and Michael Churnis, Noah Robbins and also a,
let's not forget de Miana Marchetti for production sport.
And we thought we would just go out with our final salute,
two buttons by the one,
one mechanism man created that hates a button.